so how is this happening so quickly
that's one question i get a lot
i i don't feel like i have a really
sufficient answer for it but
because i you know i was in high school
in the from 2000 2004
and uh i think it wasn't all that long
ago and i
tran transgenderism as a concept existed
i think i
heard of it a few times i didn't have
anyone in my school that identified that
way
um and we've gone from that to in a
matter of
a couple decades now it's we're at a
point now where if you're if you
if you identify as just quote-unquote
cisgender
it's strange so this is a rapid
extreme change in our culture how did it
happen so quickly do you think
well the activists were able to corrupt
many
institutions so the activists and they
are extremely
extremely aggressive were able to
corrupt both the public school system
and
infiltrate it with gender ideology which
teaches kids in california they start
at age five teaching them that only you
know your true gender
um not you know not the doctor the
doctor assigns your gender randomly but
only
you know your real one and you if you
declare it here it's a safe space we
don't have to tell your parents
so that was one force but also the
therapists
were put under tremendous pressure to go
along with this we have conversion
therapy bands in 20 states in america
now
which say that if you if a therapist
tries to convert you
out of your supposed gender identity in
other words to translate
if a gender if a therapist actually just
tries to get you comfortable in your
body and say wait a second i know you
say your problem is that you're
you were born into this body but what
about the other things we haven't
explored
um the the therapist is at risk of
losing their license
um and then when i looked into medical
organizations nearly all of them had
adoptive
affirmative care which means it's their
now their job of doctors
to rubber stamp the patient's
self-diagnosis when it comes to this one
diagnosis gender dysphoria so with
the affirmative care laws and how many
states did you say had those
20 states have conversion therapy bands
okay so
conversion therapy is if you if you help
a boy remain
a boy then you are converting him into
what he already is
which makes a lot of sense but is it
so the if affirmative care so if a if a
child comes into
the counselor and says they experience
they're experiencing confusion about
their gender or discomfort
the therapist is not allowed to explore
any other cause for that confusion or
discomfort they have to they have to
immediately jump to gender dysphoria and
transgenderism is that is that what it
is
well that's effectively what affirmative
care pressures them to do and if they go
against that
they are at risk of losing their license
they could easily be accused of running
a foul of the standard
which is don't don't try to convert a
child into the
into being cisgender um obviously this
grew out of the
anti-homosexuality conversion um
you know process you know attempts that
were you know
historically could be quite grisly um
and so
they passed these laws and people
unthinkingly went along with them
even though they had inserted gender
identity language into the bands
now gender dysphoria historically was
always treated holistically it was
always treated
with wait a second i know you think your
problem is gender but let's talk about
how you arrived at that why don't you
want to be a boy i mean that's the kind
of exploration
that therapy really required um now it's
prohibited
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat
appreciated